David Cameron will you put to bed rumors
that you plan to cut out tax credit and
restrict our benefits to children I
don't want to do that if you believe as
I do we should go on reforming welfare
making sure that work always pays
helping people back into work and
keeping working people's taxes down
that's my program and then receive a
demand for bedroom tax for the spare
room that disabled daughter has left
behind that is not a country I want to
hand on to my child
ed Miliband will stand here in a few
minutes time he is saying go on with a
budget deficit forever what was that I
set up is that you debate with him
directly instead of pointing fingers why
do you think boaters don't trust your
party with our NHS there's another when
my disabled son was desperately ill it
was always there for me and I would
always make sure it is there for other
families in our country surely anybody
with half a brain can see that the NHS
isn't sustainable in its present form
just pouring more and more money into it
disagree with people but I I don't agree
with you sir I actually think you're
wrong all of these questions are being
asked to have a moral dimension and you
keep answering them in terms of
economics
I'd like you to engage a little bit more
with the mould I mentioned that these
questions arise to me helping someone to
get a job has a moral dimension it gives
them the dignity and pride that comes
with work building a house that a young
family can afford to buy and own that's
got a moral dimension because it gives
them a stake in the country they live in
David Cameron thank you very much ed
Miliband please
five years ago the outgoing Labor
Treasury Minister left a message there's
no money left how can we trust the
Labour Party with the UK economy there
was a global financial crisis there was
a high deficit that deficit hasn't been
cleared it will be the mission of my
government to cut the deficit every year
and balance the books
first of all we'll have fair taxes
secondly we'll protect key areas like
health and education but outside those
key areas there will be fools in
spending but the final thing concerns
your living standards we see living
standards fall over this Parliament as a
result lower living standards means
lower tax revenues the government and
that's why the deficit hasn't been
cleared if your party would empower do
you think you could ever bridge the gap
between the richest and the poorest
what's your name it's Charlie
Shirley yeah it's a great question
Shirley and let me answer it directly
yes how can you stand there and say you
didn't overspend and end up bankrupting
this country frankly just lying I'm not
going to cut your tax credits I'm not
gonna cut child benefit or means test it
I think I'll be the wrong thing to do
for our country let me be playing we're
not gonna do a deal with the Scottish
National Party we're not going to have a
coalition he was saying at the end David
Cameron that if you didn't get a
majority it meant this business of going
into a darkened room with Nick Clegg now
I don't like that sound of that at all
for a whole range of reasons it's a vote
for yourself okay crap ones to see the
welfare bill skyrocket know under a
Labour government when people come here
they won't get benefits for at least the
first two years thank you very much you
sue them thank you would you welcome
Nick Clegg
you promise on student loans is
destroyed your reputation why would we
ever believe anything else you say got
it wrong I said sorry musically no less
secondly I hope you can you can at least
give me credit for the many many other
things that I have actually put into
practice whether it's taking lots of
people on low pay out of paying any
income tax the biggest expansion of
apprenticeships this country's ever seen
the biggest reform of our pension system
in a generation more money into local
into schools to help with the education
of disadvantaged children more childcare
shared parental leave so if hindsight
would you go into coalition in 2010 okay
yes absolutely I David Cameron Webb
Miliband are gonna walk into number 10
its Prime Minister I don't think that's
much in doubt and that you have to
decide which of those two the real
question is who's going to go in there
alongside them is it gonna be Alex
Salmond is it gonna be Nigel Farage or
is gonna me be me in the Liberal
Democrats that's all well and good but
you've just told us that in 2010 you had
to make a very difficult decision on
tuition fees how do we know that you
won't have to make a very difficult
decision again around the things that
you're promising is tonight no it's a
totally fair challenge and that's why
I've been much clearer and Christopher I
hope maybe I didn't hear it about the
the red lines which without which the
Liberal Democrats simply won't go into
into code in any coalition government so
for instance education spending yeah I
just wondered if you've got plans for a
new job after next week when you become
unemployed in your part it becomes an
irrelevance charming no I don't every
day that I have been in government over
the last five years I've always tried to
take decisions where we spread the
burden as fairly as possible free
movement within the EU is it creating a
problem in the UK I think it did create
a problem when free movement became kind
of the same as the freedom to claim I
decided as Deputy Prime Minister in this
coalition government to break that link
so that people couldn't arrive here from
elsewhere in the European Union and
claim benefits no questions asked on the
first day they arrived very much they
need an ice cream crowd so thank you